this is a production of Cornell
University
hi this is Frank Rossi for the Cornell
turfgrass video log and we're here right
after Hurricane Irene and sort of
thinking about all the downed trees
everywhere and looking at all the dead
grass that we've seen this season mostly
from acute heat stress and excessive
moisture in comparison to 2010 when we
had sort of chronic heat stress and dry
conditions so now as we're trying to
recover our turf grass areas we've got
to keep in mind that while we can get
some of these seedlings established and
you see the nose hair sort of nose hair
seedlings breaking through we've still
got that algal crust to deal with that's
got to be regularly disrupted and you
can do that with vertical mowing or with
needle tiny just to sort of break
through that sealed off layer but now is
an important time to look at your site
and don't fight that site try to improve
those air movement areas try to get some
of those trees down to improve am light
penetration and recognizing that a
little bit of afternoon shade might not
be the worst thing when you get into
high heat stress periods again start
considering how you might amend your
site think about a master plan for
improving those growing conditions as
well as when you start recovering these
areas if that surface gets sealed off
and you see those new seedlings coming
through try to break through those
crusted areas to keep water moving
through those areas and this is true for
golf courses as well as soccer goal
mouths thank you for joining me for the
Cornell turfgrass video log
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu